this morning we're taking a look at
Columbia South Carolina in our
continuing series American Voices to see
how national issues are playing out on
the local level under the watch of Mayor
Steve Benjamin Columbia became the first
city in the u.s. to outlaw the
attachment of bum stock gun accessories
last year
Benjamin's work to fight climate change
and committed South Carolina's capital
to 100% clean energy by 2036 the
Democratic mayor also worked to improve
relations between police and local
communities by launching the justice for
all initiative he is a president of the
nonpartisan US Conference of Mayors and
mayor Benjamin who he says guys we can
call him Steve joins us at the table
hello Steve I'm gonna call you mayor
Benjamin it's very good to have you here
it's exciting to be here thank you we
have heard that the mayor's are
committed you said the tone is to appeal
to the better angels of us now I
remember in middle school that's from
Lincoln's Gettysburg Gettysburg Address
why do you think that we need to appeal
the better angels of us that was back in
the 1800s this is 2018 we live in the
greatest democratic nation in the
history of the world but no but no if we
need to make sure that remains so we can
only do that by making sure we continue
to work together
America's mayors are driving this
American experiment cities and
metropolitan economy is now account for
85 percent of our population
ninety percent of all jobs ninety 1.2
percent of all American GDP 20 trillion
dollars it's created in seeds in
metropolitan economies new innovations
as a how we deal with public health
issues
how would preparing for 5g and advent of
of these new innovative technologies
it's I mean it's all happening in cities
so but you said you were specifically
concerned about the time
if we're not working together if we
can't have a dialogue around what are
facts or how and how we're going to make
sure that not only my family thrives
with your family also survives I remain
convinced in South Carolina if you take
a legal pad and I write down the 10 most
important things to me and my family and
I asked someone who shares with
completely different demographic with
the 10 most important things are there
eight things on that list that
that that we all agree on we should work
together on those eight things and then
appear in an era of mutual respect and
other to well work the democratic
process we'll find we'll fight through
that Jim fallows and Deb fellows wrote a
book about the communities and they said
there was a simple test if you went to a
community and they didn't talk much
about national politics it was a healthy
local community to the extent that
people were obsessed with national
politics in Washington that meant it was
not so healthy there do you think that
that was first of all they're an
inspiration they're an inspiration and
in that type of a deep dive into
American cities and towns does yes
reveal the fact that that we love each
other we love working together that you
get into some of these communities in
the heart of Appalachia on the heartland
and you actually find immigrant
communities working with with families
who've been there for generations as
long as you're dealing with in a local
level and regardless what's happening in
Washington Washington people are talking
over each other yelling at each other
it's infecting state capitals on the
local level local leaders are working
together every single day to continue
this this wonderful American experiment
we've got we've got to push that out and
our focus at the conference of mayors if
it may say this next two years so
bipartisan focus on on building American
infrastructure on focusing on building
innovation economy and working on
building inclusive city you have to do
more on infrastructure because the
federal government doesn't do its job
well right now the reality is that we're
building the vast majority of American
infrastructure now 80% of all all
infrastructure is built by cities in
state governments and we catch the water
sewer infrastructure 98.5% is built by
us with 1.5 percent coming from the
federal government
the reality is depending who you're
talking to either two trillion or five
point two trillion dollars is needed in
the American infrastructure we have
terracotta pipes in the ground 200 years
old in cities and towns across America
if we're going to compete with or
without our friends in Europe and in
Asia and even some developing countries
in other parts of the world we've got to
make sure we start investing in American
infrastructure it would be wonderful to
have a partner in Washington DC but
American cities are committed to leading
even in spite of that the president has
withdrawn from the Paris climate
agreement and yet Mayor Bloomberg who
was here talked about how cities though
can do a lot in terms of
greener your energy what's Colombia
doing I tell you I'm thankful to Mayor
Bloomberg for his leadership all across
this country America our city with
climate manners I partnered with the
Sierra Club and mayor's Kevin Faulkner
Francis Suarez from San Diego and Miami
respectively exactly this good ski from
Salt Lake bipartisan leadership to
commit to clean and renewable energy
about 2036 and mayor is important in
this discussion because when you start
talking to people about how do we stop
the earth from warming 1.5 degrees
Celsius to where it was before the
industrial revolution people's eyes
glaze over yes but but a mayor can talk
to someone and say okay your child
suffering with asthma yeah let me show
you what we can do to help deal with
that if we put some solar panels on your
roof we can cut your bill by $200 and
helps with your income issues and this
issue of income volatility that's
affecting families we can have a real
conversation with people and in Colombia
we've made this commitment and we're
working with our local partners are
trying to make sure we we focus on
cleaning with Nova image and for all
city to ban attachments of the bum
stocks we gun stocks bump stocks and
trigger cranks most people didn't know
what they were before Las Vegas now we
all know if they are in common sense
policymakers Republican Democrat all to
act to ban them all across the country
alright Mayor Steve Benjamin thanks so
much for they here with us